c'est de trouver le chercher chez moi je
trouve à vous de les trouver
moi je trouve vous avez beaucoup de
femmes
nous notre vie à gg c'est pas que
j'aimais beaucoup fait bouger mais le
principe même de la femme donc j'aime
encore le fasse et théorique
oui mais oui mais c'est indispensable
parce que session si on aime le principe
même de l'homme ce que je comprends
parfaitement ses on entre dans une autre
catégorie
mais moi c'est le cfmc vraiment la femme
que j'ai eu quelques jeunes je trouve
que tout ça plus mieux plus puristes ou
sans doute plus costaud en tout cas plus
gracieux que l'homme que nous sommes des
grands bateaux par rapport par rapport
aux femmes sans votre première femme
vous auriez fait du cinéma jaurès et du
cinéma mais sans doute que quelques
années plus tard madeleine
truffaut enfin extrait faut disait une
chose dans le film sur fond soit très
très oui bien sûr que j'ai des fonds spa
faire ce film et mon père sur ce bouquin
françois l'a aidé à faire son premier
film puisqu'il était distributeurs mais
quoi ça c'est l'avancée d'une année ce
qui est ce qui est à peu près vrai moi
disons que ça m'a devancée de deux ans
parce que je suis là donc deux ans je
suppose que deux ans après je vais jouer
je jouerai je ne suis pas mais c'est
vrai qu'avec celles qu'elle pignon en
fait c'était c'était sa grand mère qui
est morte qui est comme on a des parts
alors on a pris l'argent et on en a pris
tout le pognon qu'on pouvait trouver les
lieux et mes parents m'ont dit vous ne
donne rien parce que si vous n'avez plus
rien vous serez bien content de trouver
le script est un argument c'est à dire
l'union ne peut pas dire très très très
audacieux mais prudence exprimée
l'arrière garde et ensuite ça vous a
mené vers les chemins d'un autre amant
alors alors ensuite oui réduit seulement
de mezouar sa première femme nombreux
non non non général je me suis toujours
débrouillé pour que pour qu'elle soit
contente de se débarrasser de moi j'ai
été très bien élevés qu'en france
pour ce genre de chose si on quitte une
femme c'est terrible mais c'est en plus
c'est le jour gred c'est honteux
le système de débrouille et pourtant
vous n'êtes pas pour qu'au contraire on
le dit que presque bon débarras stéphane
audran qui le court tout votre oeuvre
cinématographique qu'est ce qui vous a
plu en elle la première fois que vous
l'avez rencontrée je trouvais plus gold
de se trouver belle info girondins
freinant genre belle femme ça et est
marrante ce qu'on lui donne et semi
arides aux nuances entre 200 à rigoler
surtout connu du continent arrigoni
mais d'ailleurs quand on s'est quittés
bizarrement c'est presque continuelle
parce que c'est très difficile d'être
pas une actrice parce que déjà vous avez
en face de vous tendre pendant les repas
puis vous arrivez au tournage vous
regardez dans la regarder dans la
gestion de la caméra qui sourit elle
encore
tiens pas obligée d'engager pas dans
tous des lyonnais dont beaucoup notre
4,5 et alors c'est la même femme
finalement oui mais bien sûr derrière
oui c'est oui
seule parade de vie commune et 5 0 mais
j'ai expérimenté
oui c'est la même elle peut jouer
n'importe quel rôle c'est la même quand
même et donc à l'arrivée je me suis dit
finalement et c'était plus agréable de
travailler avec quelques degrés et nous
à nous avons d'abord étudier la question
est très très simplement et courtoise de
part et d'autre il faut dire
qu'auparavant une petite anecdote c'est
que comme nos relations se relâcher un
petit peu
je disais mais il n'ya pas me voir sur
quel ton âge et de dire robin non-écoute
fond d'oeil sera sous-traitée bond alors
qu'est ce que ce faire il me dit de me
disait m'a dit t'as qu'à baiser la
scripps effectivement et c'est ce que
j'ai fait ou pourquoi pas oui
et voilà et c'est fait pour une fois que
j'ai trouvé ma troisième épouse parce
que quand on souhaite on se sépare tu ne
sais pas vraiment c'est quand on a
trouvé quelqu'un d'autre
les tips pas les femmes ou si je pense
même et les les types en tout cas je
crois que oui c'est ça ils sont un peu
lâche le pape de la cuisine dans le
problème de la nicotine de la maison
[Musique]
toujours et le type avec sa gouvernante
c'est plutôt discret du rni donc ici on
est chez vous chez votre femme joue
moins mais chez moi mais
m'enfin ce chez eux aussi parce que
disons que la totalité du jardin fait
elle presque la totalité de la maison
ici avenue nommage mais je me contente
de jouer les vaches à lait pouvez vous
aimez des femmes avec qui vous ne
travaillez pas alors c'est une bonne
question je ne suis pas sûr j'en suis
pas sûr enfin maintenant je ne sera pas
alors là ma femme ce qui est formidable
c'est qu'elle n'est pas en face de moi
l'état côté alors donc on vit
normalement tu
et quoi de plus beau que lorsqu'on du
monde y est j'ai envie de voir ma femme
un petit panneau elle est là mais je
n'ai pas envie de la voir
hop un petit panneau on voit les acteurs
on travaille cet épatant dans ses jeunes
années
[Musique]